home price growth has continued to climb
to a new record in july numbers are just
in july was the fourth consecutive month
of record price appreciation and it
marked the highest annual rate of price
growth since the end index began in
1987. absolutely nuts the median
existing home sales price in august of
this year rose fourteen point nine
percent from a year earlier to three
hundred and fifty six thousand seven
hundred dollars that's right there's a
fifteen percent increase in the median
existing home sales price in america
households that bought homes in may are
spending almost 21 of their income on
monthly mortgage payments which is above
the average rate for the past decade and
we've got a couple of charts here that
we're going to show the first is the
july home price growth surges
this is a absolutely nuts chart this
chart is showing that the year-over-year
change in july of 2021 was nearly 20
home prices up from the year before
pretty nuts the second one is while
price growth varies all metro areas are
up double digits so it doesn't matter
where you live if you live in a metro in
the united states home prices are up in
phoenix over 30 year-over-year san diego
over 25
if you look at somewhere like las vegas
or miami over 20
and still even places like washington
minneapolis and chicago up over 10 or 15
percent absolutely nuts and then if you
look at this last chart that we have the
u.s home prices are 44
above their prior peak and so when you
look at this specifically we had the
prior pre uh peak during the housing
crisis everyone thought wow this is
super overvalued we never should see
these levels in home prices but today
currently we are 44 higher than we were
right during that housing crisis that is
the u.s on a blended basis in a place
like denver the home prices are double
what they were during the housing crisis
dallas seattle portland and charlotte
all over 50
as well and so bill help us understand
why exactly uh home prices are exploding
like this because it's actually a pretty
complex situation in terms of why
they're going up so much but what's kind
of your read on this well i think you
have to get back to basics right so
supply and demand everybody knows about
supply and demand let's look at demand
for a second you have a situation where
covet happened and literally the federal
government came in and started buying
mortgage-backed securities if the
federal government hadn't bought the
mortgage-backed securities you'd have a
real problem
because liquidity would dry up in the
mortgage bond market and the mortgage
bond market is actually what creates a
lot of liquidity in in you know in the
mortgage industry so you have this
incredible fuel for demand which is you
have the federal government buying
mortgage-backed securities you have
low interest rates which were reduced
even further in covid so on the demand
side of things you just have gasoline on
the fire and then on the supply side you
have the situation where kovid created i
would argue potentially the biggest
supply issue that the industry's ever
seen in the form of you know starting
stopping you have the lumber prices
going up and and all this stuff so if
you look at the demand and you look at
the supply it's just creating an
environment pump where you know the
prices just have gotten unbelievable
levels now the interesting thing will be
what happens in you know as we get into
2022 halfway through toward the end
toward the end of 2022 will some
capacity come back online so you're able
to get that supply up if you can get the
supply back up what can happen is you
can start to see some moderating in the
prices but for now those two things
affecting the supply and demand as i
described are just creating an
environment where you know
good luck keeping it it's like keeping a
beach ball under water help us
understand like the supply chain
disruptions right in terms of uh i think
most people are like oh i know that
there's low interest rates i kind of
sort of know that people are looking for
homes so the demand side they can wrap
their head around but the supply chain i
just they don't see that every day right
it's like what do you understand is
going on well it's in part caused by the
demand side so i don't want to say oh
it's just all supply it's also the fact
as i said that the federal government
and most people don't talk about this i
think it will actually happen in future
elections
but people don't talk about it right now
the federal government has essentially
gone in and bought large portions of the
mortgage bond market that's a that's a
huge issue so i don't want to i don't
want to dismiss that in terms of supply
issues you know when covet happened i
think that naturally all the
manufacturers and you see this across
every every industry right you guys see
it too and i'm sure everybody sees it
with with food and whatnot but everybody
you know forecasted okay we're gonna
we're gonna wind down we're gonna we're
gonna you know tighten up our balance
sheet we're going to uh you know slow
things down and then all of a sudden you
started to see the federal government
come in the mortgage bond market you
started to see liquidity stay there i
mean there was a period of time where
they didn't know what was going to
happen with the mortgage bond market and
um
and so you know naturally these home
builders were saying whoa you know i
don't know if we should really be
building this much so then they had all
of a sudden restart the race right and
you this time you're restarting the race
with lower interest rates
you had the federal government buying
the mortgage-backed securities and so um
it's just been a natural game of
catch-up and that's what it's been i
mean it's it's been unbelievable i think
it's been the biggest supply shock that
the the industry's ever seen and i know
we're seeing that in other industries as
well yeah what feels uh even worse is
like when you get the home prices going
up uh some of that naturally was just
going to happen by people wanting to
move out of cities move into suburban
areas uh you get the imbalance of supply
demand so forget all the monetary and
fiscal policy stuff like there already
was going to be higher price points just
because of this when you layer in the
monetary and fiscal policy stuff then
also it just explodes i mean 20 increase
right in terms of home prices from july
of last year to this year
sure you can say there's a base effect
in terms of prices went down during the
summer last year whatever you want to
say no you take the 20 out of the
mortgage market you'll see those prices
go down rapidly yeah why do you think
the government buying the
mortgage-backed securities is so uh
concerning because
and i do think it is but i not saying
so much concerning as much as it's a
reality now i mean the mortgage industry
you know has had third party providers
who provided liquidity almost like a
market maker type situation
but when the federal government it's
much like um you know with interest
rates and the government backstopping
buying the government the government
buys treasury bonds right
it just creates this confidence that
people have to keep the liquidity going
and so if you feel that the government's
always going to bail you out in the in
the instance of mortgages right uh are
you going to be concerned is about risk
as much as you would if there wasn't the
government there right yeah so if you
take if if you take the risk off the
table you know then you're looking back
at uh
you know some pretty risky things that
can happen what do you guys think
actually before you guys answer real
quick uh we're at 3.2 k likes right now
if you all get us to 4 000 likes john
will give away a thousand bucks and i'll
do it i'll do a thousand at 5
there we go he finally shows up
stimulation
should i put out a tweet and get it to
five thousand let's see if we can get
there uh on the count of three i'm gonna
count to three press the like button
when we hit 4 000 likes then john will
go ahead and give away a thousand bucks
one two three press that thumbs up
button so more people on youtube see
this content and they can learn
alongside you
all right what do you guys think about
the uh increasing home prices
uh well i'm actually i'm shocked that
it's it's uh lasted this long and this
consistently across all parts of the
country right so if you look at kind of
the charts that we were showing earlier
it's not very uh it's not it's some
cities yeah sure five ten percent up
some are 20 las vegas i saw this up 22
uh last month but it's just like bill
said right it's just supply and demand
people are moving uh there's not enough
inventory in the market and people are
willing to pay much higher cost and not
only that but there's investors that are
going out and purchasing a lot of these
properties that's another big issue
right yeah so like when you look at it
from the the context of just even
literally a simple supply and demand a
lot more of it starts to make sense um
but we're going to see how long it lasts
for i think people are getting worried
that they're not going to be able to
afford or be able to move or be able to
purchase new homes uh already at some of
the prices that were that we're seeing
existing now so we'll see like if this
lasts for another three four five months
where prices continue to climb up over
time it's going to be a real issue
over over time obviously the prices have
increased i saw a study that bloomberg
did the other day that basically was
like if you want to put that 20 down on
the average home in america it uh it's
going up and up and upright so now it's
you have to save for 10 years so the
lower income people in america are
actually getting hit harder than that
it's gonna be harder to find home and
it's gonna take longer to kind of get um
into a home which can be seen as both an
asset and a liability right as a
standpoint but just owning a home is
very important and uh unfortunately it's
going to take longer to do that yeah the
other piece that becomes really
interesting is when you layer on the
increasing home prices uh that means
that everyone in a neighborhood the
value of their home is going up if the
value of their homes going up and we get
the unrealized capital gains tax now all
of a sudden
and i think that this is probably the
key piece are people going to be forced
to sell their homes to pay the
unrealized capital gains tax right if
you think of the average american
majority of their net worth is in their
home so let's say that you own a 250 000
house and you've got a mortgage on it
you're paying off that mortgage and
you've got you know let's say 50 000 of
cash in your bank account you got some
stocks whatever but the home is the
majority of your net worth
you don't have enough cash to pay if the
home goes up 20 percent
but that you just you you can't pay out
of your bank account or whatever without
putting yourself in a dire financial
position to pay that tax and so i don't
think we're going to get in a world
where we want people selling their homes
to pay for a tax on an unrealized
capital gains which either means that
there's got to be a carve out or they're
going to have to say look this
unrealized capital gain sticks nuts yeah
i mean that's why it makes no sense
right
it's not gonna happen yeah it's it's
do do we think that uh we've got craig
lazara i think is the uh quote that we
have here uh who said quote the last
several months have been extraordinary
not only in the level of price gains but
in the consistency of gains across the
country and then we've got danielle hale
who's the chief economist for
realtor.com said demand remains quite
high relative to just about any other
period in history which is what's
driving higher than normal price
increases and so both of these folks
seem to be highlighting demand uh or
looking at things around the
extraordinary length of this
but i think again i just go back to like
how much is just the dollar being
devalued right it's just monetary and
fiscal policy stuff playing out like
it feels like that's harder to to point
to it's harder to grasp like hey how is
this working and so it's easy to oh
demands up right of course prices go up
or oh there's supply chain issues
construction companies uh one thing i
heard was some construction companies
were pausing new construction builds
when lumber prices were exploding
because they were saying uh hey i can't
price your home because i literally
don't know what the price of the goods
is and that's true but i think it's just
a confluence of all these events right
and to your point yeah you can sum it up
to the dollar being down for example but
that's where i'm getting at with the fed
uh buying these mortgage-backed
securities is
what are they buying it with
they're buying it with u.s dollars right
yeah and so you know you talk about m2
and the velocity of money right at what
point does that all catch up but i think
they're probably going to taper
uh
the mortgage-backed security buying
pretty soon so it'll be interesting to
see what happens what do you
um i think that they're going to
probably reduce it because it's almost
like emergency like conditions i mean
there was a real concern for a period of
a few days in early 2020 that the
mortgage bond market was going to blow
up and if it wasn't for this outside
force meaning the government coming in
and doing it so i think they'll probably
lessen the amount of bonds that they're
buying and uh you know maybe you'll see
an uptick in rates but i still think
because of all the issues we discussed
the confluence of things
it's still going to be a hot market
i was looking at a chart uh a minute ago
here from charlie uh bellow
charlie he kills yeah he's a good father
but so he was showing the media and home
prices uh in the us over the last 10
years in august 20 in august 2011 the
median home price was 220 000
and this august it's 391 000 so it's
almost nearly doubled in the last decade
so super scary stuff there but then when
you also look at the uh the the median
home price compared to someone's income
it's 5.8 times higher than their median
household income now the average home
price which is the highest it's ever
been on record
5.8 times someone's income their house
the median house in the u.s that's nuts
yeah hey guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today and don't forget to check out our
partner sofi they make all this possible
they're a super app that lets you save
spend borrow earn and invest all from
one single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from sofa
not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.com
download the app and go ahead and open
an account
software.compomp and make sure you come
back and watch more of the best business
show we're going to build the biggest
business show in the world and we need
your help